I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. That's us. Hey there. We are here. We are here and we're excited because today we're talking about Hot Girl. Hot Girl season one, episode six, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Amy Heckerling. I was really excited to meet Amy Heckerling, you know, growing up. Guys, I might be a child of the 70s. No judgment. The oldie sitting here. No. And she directed
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你带来《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。就是我们。大家好。我们到了。我们到了，而且很兴奋，因为今天要聊的是“辣妹”。“辣妹”第一季第六集，由敏迪·卡林编剧，艾米·海克林执导。我真的很兴奋能见到艾米·海克林，你知道的，从小看着她的作品长大的。伙计们，我可能是一个70年代的孩子。不予评判。老古董就坐在这儿。不是的。她还执导了
Fast Times at Ridgemont High and Clueless. Clueless. Clueless. So I was excited. I remember there was a bit of a buzz. Yeah, there was a little bit of a buzz. That she was coming in. We were very excited. I didn't know how to make small talk with her. And guess what? I failed. All right, Jenna, hit us with a synopsis. All right. Synopsis of this episode. Michael allows a woman selling purses to set up in the conference room for the day and Michael and Dwight compete for her attention. Very simple. Very simple. And yet. So loaded for Pam. This was really a big Pam episode. It really was. So should we start with some fast facts then? I know you want to. You know. My fast fact, number one, this is the first
《开放的学期》和《独领风骚》。《独领风骚》。《独领风骚》。所以我很兴奋。我记得当时引起了一些轰动。是的，确实引起了一些轰动。她要来。我们非常兴奋。我都不知道该怎么和她闲聊。结果呢？我搞砸了。好了，珍娜，给我们讲讲剧情梗概吧。好的。这一集的剧情梗概。迈克尔允许一个卖包的女人在会议室摆摊一天，迈克尔和德怀特为了吸引她的注意而展开竞争。非常简单。非常简单。然而。对帕姆来说信息量太大了。这确实是一集以帕姆为核心的大戏。确实如此。那我们是不是该从一些速查小百科开始？我知道你想这么干。你知道的。我的速查小百科第一条，这是第一集
episode written by Mindy Kaling. Yes. Mindy Kaling's so smart, so funny. And she was one of our most prolific writers on the office. She wrote a total of, Jenna, ready? What? 22 episodes. Wow. I know. That's like she wrote an entire season of the office. I know. Of our night. Because the season's usually about 22, 24 episodes. I have a fan question about Mindy. All right. This is from Bear. Hi, Bear. Yes. Bear asked, this episode was written by Mindy Kaling. What was it like to work with her as a writer versus an actor? Oh, Bear. Good question. I know. You know what? I loved when Mindy was the writer of the episode. Because the writer of the episode on our show would stay on set all week and
由敏迪·卡林编剧的剧集。是的。敏迪·卡林太聪明了，太搞笑了。她也是我们在《办公室》里最多产的编剧之一。她总共写了，珍娜，准备好了吗？什么？22集。哇。我知道。这简直就像她一个人写了《办公室》的一整季。我知道。在我们的晚间节目里。因为一季通常大约是22到24集。我有一个关于敏迪的粉丝提问。好的。这是贝尔提问的。嗨，贝尔。是的。贝尔问，这一集是由敏迪·卡林编剧的。作为编剧和作为演员，跟她合作有什么不同吗？噢，贝尔。好问题。我知道。你知道吗？我特别喜欢敏迪担任一集编剧的时候。因为在我们剧里，单集编剧会一整周都留在片场
produce their episode with the director. So they kind of worked very side by side with the director. Yes. And they were sort of the liaison back to the writer's room. I love that our show did this. Not all shows do that. And I really think you benefit from having the writer of the episode on the set with you. Well, Mindy, it was so easy to make Mindy laugh. Like she was so ready to love everything you were doing. You were filled with such confidence when Mindy was on the set. And she also was really good on the spot coming up with new jokes. Cause that was another thing that the writer of the episode would do. They would pitch you improvisations on the spot. Yeah. And Mindy, for me, as someone
跟导演一起制作他们的那一集。所以他们跟导演的合作非常紧密。是的。而且他们某种程度上也是与编剧室对接的联络人。我太喜欢我们剧组这样做。并非所有剧组都这样。我真的觉得让这一集的编剧和你们一起在片场，你们会受益匪浅。嗯，敏迪，逗敏迪笑太容易了。就好像她随时准备好去喜欢你做的一切。当敏迪在片场时，你浑身都充满了自信。而且她也非常擅长即兴想出新的笑话。因为这也是单集编剧会做的事。他们会当场向你提出即兴表演的建议。是的。而敏迪对我来说，作为一个
with like an improv background, I loved being able to pitch to Mindy because she's so smart. So I could like say, Hey Mindy, could I, you know, try this? And then she would just instantly be like, Oh, that'd be great. Or how about you do this? Like she was such a wonderful creative collaborator. I always felt like Mindy was such a big advocate for the character of Pam as well. I think she was in the writer's room pitching storylines for Pam. And this was a very Pam centered episode. As we said, Pam has feelings. Pam has a lot of feelings. Pam has a lot of feelings. She does. This leads me into my second fastback. I was texting with Mindy about this episode in preparation and she told me something. What? The original
有即兴表演背景的人，我非常喜欢向敏迪提议，因为她太聪明了。所以我会说，嘿，敏迪，我能，你知道，试试这个吗？然后她就会马上说，哦，那太棒了。或者你这样演怎么样？她真是一个非常棒的创意合作伙伴。我一直觉得敏迪也是帕姆这个角色的巨大拥护者。我想她在编剧室里为帕姆争取过剧情线。正如我们所说，这一集是以帕姆为中心的故事。帕姆有情绪。帕姆有很多情绪。帕姆有很多情绪。她确实有。这让我想到了我的第二个速查小百科。我在准备期间跟敏迪发短信聊到这一集，她告诉我一件事。什么？最初的
title of this episode was purse girl. Do you kind of remember that? I actually do because I feel like I have referred to this as purse girl a few times cause it's in my brain. Yeah. She also told me that her original draft of this was 39 pages, which is a lot because usually the number of pages that a script is, that's how many minutes of screen time it is. So her script, if we did it exactly as written would have been 39 minutes, which we would not have been able to air. I really wish we could have done that. And I wish we could have filmed all 40 pages of that instead of 22, 22 minutes. I remember they used to have those very long table drafts and then they would cut a bunch of stuff out and they
这集的标题是“包包女孩”。你有点印象吗？我其实还真有，因为我觉得我好几次都把这集叫作“包包女孩”，因为它已经在我的脑海里了。是的。她还告诉我，她最初的初稿有39页，这非常多，因为通常剧本的页数就是银幕时间的分钟数。所以她的剧本，如果我们完全按原样拍摄，就会有39分钟，那是我们根本无法播出的。我真希望我们当时能做到。我真希望我们能把那40页全部拍下来，而不是22分钟，22分钟。我记得他们过去常有非常长的围读剧本，然后他们会删掉一堆东西，并
would make something they called the candy bag. Yeah. And those were all of the cut scenes or they were additional takes on scenes. So whatever talking head wound up in the script, there would be five different takes on that talking head in the candy bag. And so we would sit down to do our talking heads and they would say, all right, well, we're going to do the scripted one, but then we're going to do three of them from the candy bag. Oh, I remember going to do a talking head and they handed me three pages of alts, like right in the minute. I'm like, oh, right. Okay. I'm going to have to have a photographic memory. You have to really be on your toes. I think that's something that it kept us on our toes
制作他们称之为“糖果包”的东西。是的。那些都是被剪掉的场景，或者是场景的额外镜头。无论哪个访谈镜头最终写进剧本，在“糖果包”里都会有关于那个访谈镜头的五种不同拍法。所以当我们坐下来拍访谈镜头时，他们会说，好吧，我们要拍剧本里的那一条，但接着我们要拍“糖果包”里的三条。哦，我记得有一次去做访谈镜头，他们直接塞给我三页备选台词，就在那一分钟。我说，哦，好吧。好吧。我得有摄影记忆才行。你必须时刻保持高度警惕。我觉得这确实是一点，它让我们
for sure. I loved it. I loved it too. And then they used to let me play around and like sort of like put my spin on it too, which was always fun. All right. Fisher, what else you got? All right. I think it's time to talk about Amy Adams. Okay. I have a lot of note cards here in front of me. I see. And a lot of them have the words Amy or Amy Adams. You tell me when you're ready because I've got a note card ready to go. Well, this is our third fast fact. Okay. Amy Adams was the purse girl. Mindy told me that Amy was her favorite from the very beginning. This is who she wanted to cast as the purse girl from her audition. But something that I think people don't realize is that Amy Adams wasn't
时刻保持警惕，那是肯定的。我喜欢。我也很喜欢。然后他们过去还允许我自由发挥，把我的个人特色也融入进去，这总是很有趣。好了。菲舍尔，你还有什么？好的。我觉得是时候聊聊艾米·亚当斯了。好的。我面前有很多索引卡。我看到了。它们上面有很多都写着“艾米”或“艾米·亚当斯”。你随时告诉我准备好了没，因为我手头已经准备好一张索引卡了。嗯，这是我们的第三个速查小百科。好的。艾米·亚当斯就是那个“包包女孩”。敏迪告诉我，从一开始艾米就是她的最爱。这就是她从试镜中就想选来演“包包女孩”的人。但我觉得大家可能没有意识到的一点是，艾米·亚当斯在被选为“包包女孩”时，还不是
Amy Adams when she was cast as the purse girl. She became Amy Adams later. And that's an interesting story actually because we filmed this episode in the fall of 2004, but they didn't start airing until the spring of 2005. And that fall, she was nominated for an Academy Award for her role in Junebug. Right. When she did this episode of the office, no one had seen Junebug yet because Junebug came out in August of 2005. And I remember her first day on set. We were talking and I was like, how are things going? She's like, well, you know, it's good. I mean, I was on a show on CBS called Dr. Vegas, but they like, they let me go. Oh, that's right. She was like, I kind of got fired. And I was like, no.
后来那个大名鼎鼎的艾米·亚当斯。她是在那之后才成为艾米·亚当斯的。这其实是一个有趣的故事，因为我们是在2004年秋天拍摄这一集的，但它们直到2005年春天菜开始播出。就在那个秋天，她凭借在电影《六月虫》中的角色获得了奥斯卡最佳女配角提名。没错。当她拍摄《办公室》这一集时，还没人看过《六月虫》，因为《六月虫》是在2005年8月上映的。我记得她第一天到片场时。我们聊天来着，我说，最近怎么样？她说，嗯，你知道的，挺好的。我是说，我以前在CBS的一部叫《拉斯维加斯医生》的剧里演过，但他们，他们让我走了。哦，对哦。她说，我算是被解雇了。然后我说，不会吧。
And she was like, yeah, and I was really down and I was bummed out. But then, you know, I did this little indie movie called Junebug and I felt so good about it. And it's going to come out later in the year. And I was like, oh, that sounds great. Yeah. Let me build you up, Amy Adams. Amy, you're going to be just fine. And she was. And she was. But Amy is one of the nicest people. She's so, so sweet. Oh, I loved Amy. It was so fun working with her. There were a lot of questions from fans asking if we planned to bring this character back after we shot it. Well, we didn't think we were going to have a show. Right. There were no real plans to bring her back. But then when the show got picked up, they wanted
然后她说，对啊，我当时真的很低落，也很沮丧。但后来，你知道，我拍了一部叫《六月虫》的小独立电影，我对它感觉非常好。而且它会在今年晚些时候上映。我就说，哦，听起来真不错。对。让我给你打打气，艾米·亚当斯。艾米，你会没事的。她确实没事。她真的没事。但艾米是那种最随和的人之一。她真的是太、太甜美了。哦，我很喜欢艾米。和她一起工作太有趣了。有很多粉丝提问，问我们拍完后有没有计划让这个角色回归。嗯，我们当时根本没想过我们能有一档节目。没错。当时没有让她回归的具体计划。但后来当节目被续订时，他们想要
to bring her back. But now she was Academy Award nominated Amy Adams. I was like, well, I hope we can get her back. And we did. She came back for two more episodes. Yes. And she was such a great foil to for Pam and Jim and all of that. I loved watching that play out. Not only was Amy Adams super nice on set and just like such a pleasure to work with, but I don't know, probably like two years later, I ran into her. I had a friend visiting from Alabama and you guys, I don't ever go out. So my friend was coming in town and I was like, Oh, I'm going to take her somewhere fancy. That hotel Chateau Marmont, that's fancy. We'll go there. Cause I just had it in my head. Yeah, like the Hollywood
让她回归。但现在她是获得奥斯卡提名的艾米·亚当斯了。我想说，好吧，希望我们能请回她。我们真的做到了。她回来又拍了两集。是的。对于帕姆、吉姆以及所有这些情节来说，她真的是一个绝佳的衬托。我特别喜欢看那些剧情的展开。艾米·亚当斯不仅在片场超级友善，而且合作起来简直是一种享受，而且我不知道，大概两年后，我碰到了她。我当时有个从阿拉巴马州来的朋友，伙计们，我从来不出门。所以我的朋友要来镇上，我说，哦，我要带她去个高级的地方。那个叫马尔蒙庄园的酒店，那个很高级。我们就去那儿吧。因为我脑子里就这么想的。对，就像好莱坞那种
fancy place. It was a fancy place. Yeah. I mean, it's like half an hour from my house. So it was such a like hall, but I was like, no, I'll take my friend from Alabama there. So we went and we were having dinner and Amy Adams was at a table and she sent over two glasses of champagne to my friend and I, and I was like, turn, they were like, Oh, this is a fancy move. Amy Adams. And they were like, I was like, who's this from? They were like, it's from Amy Adams. And she waved and then she came over and we chatted. Amy Adams is just a class act. I have a funny Amy Adams story about how people think that we look alike. So she and I were both at this work party thing. I can't remember exactly. I
高级的地方。那确实是个高级地方。对。我是说，离我家大概半小时车程。所以这算是一次大出动，但我当时想，不，我要带我来自阿拉巴马的朋友去那儿。于是我们去了，正在吃晚餐，艾米·亚当斯也在一张桌子旁，她给我们俩每人送了两杯香槟过来，我当时就想，天哪，他们说，哦，这举动真高级。艾米·亚当斯。他们就说，我说，这是谁送的？他们说，是艾米·亚当斯送的。然后她挥了挥手，接着她走过来和我们聊天。艾米·亚当斯真的是太有风度了。我有一个关于艾米·亚当斯的有趣故事，是关于人们觉得我们长得很像的。我和她当时都在一个工作派对上。我记不太清具体是什么了。我
think it was like honoring directors in the industry and we were both there and my friend came up to me and he said, I am so humiliated right now. And I said, what happened? And he goes, I just went up and bear hugged Amy Adams and said, Jenna, you look beautiful because he mixed us up. And this people have this thing where they think she and I look a lot alike. We really don't look anything alike in person. Although I guess I just told a story about someone who mixed us up in person. I mean, there is a resemblance. It's she's perfectly cast because there is a resemblance. And you're both like beautiful ladies. Thanks. But I see a resemblance. I feel like we could play sisters. You could. All right, Hollywood,
觉得好像是表彰行业内导演的活动，我们都在那儿，然后我的朋友走到我面前对我说，我现在感到太尴尬了。我说，怎么了？他说，我刚刚走过去给了艾米·亚当斯一个熊抱，还说，珍娜，你真漂亮。因为他把我们认错了。大家都有这种印象，觉得她和我长得很像。我们在现实中其实一点也不像。虽然我刚讲了一个在现实中把我们认错的人的故事。我是说，确实有几分相似。她选角绝对完美，因为确实有相似之处。而且你们俩都是大美女。谢谢。但我觉得有相似之处。我觉得我们可以演姐妹。你可以的。好吧，好莱坞，
you heard it here first. That's how I guess that's how I talk when I'm talking to Hollywood. I guess Hollywood beware. Hollywood. This is Angela Kinsey. I don't love it. I would rethink your character, your Hollywood voice. I think you should work on it. Give it an accent. Should it be British? I only would know. Oh, my God. That's Australian. Oh, what was that? That was like drunk Scottish. What is happening? I can't do accents. And I also can't sing. I can do Australian, but I grew up overseas and all my best friends were Aussies. So right now I'm just sitting here talking to Jenna. We're going to talk about hot girl. Yeah, it's really good. And thanks. Thanks so much. I'm shocked. I'm
你们头一个听到了。我想这就是我跟好莱坞说话时的语气吧。我想好莱坞要小心了。好莱坞。我是安吉拉·金西。我不太喜欢。我会重新考虑你的角色，你那好莱坞式的嗓音。我觉得你该练练。加个口音。要不来个英式口音？我只懂。噢，天哪。那是澳大利亚口音。噢，刚才那个是什么？那就像喝醉了的苏格兰人。怎么回事？我不会说口音。我也不会唱歌。我会说澳大利亚口音，但我是在海外长大的，我最好的朋友都是澳大利亚人。所以现在我只是坐在这里跟珍娜说话。我们要聊的是“辣妹”。对，真的很棒。谢谢。非常感谢。我很震惊。我
genuinely impressed. Okay. Okay. Okay. See, that was so good, but your Hollywood voice is a no. I know. You know what? It's whenever I'm trying to be slick. I'm just not programmed to be slick. This is true about you. I know. Before we go to a break, since we're talking about Amy Adams and how wonderful she is both on and off set, we have to tell the story about how she helped us meet Meryl Streep. Oh my God. Oh my God. I cannot believe I didn't put that on a note card. I can't believe it. What is wrong with me? You know what? I don't know. I got here. There were donuts. I got excited. I forgot. Okay. So one year, we got to go to the Golden Globes. Oh, the office had been nominated. And I have to say, first
真的是佩服。好吧。好吧。好吧。你看，刚才那个学得挺好，但你那好莱坞嗓音就算了吧。我知道。你知道吗？每当我试图表现得圆滑时。我天生就不是圆滑的人。你确实是这样。我知道。在我们进入中场休息之前，既然我们在谈论艾米·亚当斯以及她在片场内外是多么的棒，我们必须讲讲她是如何帮我们见到梅丽尔·斯特里普的故事。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我真不敢相信我没把这个写在索引卡上。我真不敢相信。我这是怎么了？你知道吗？我不知道。我来到这儿。这里有甜甜圈。我太激动了。我给忘了。好吧。所以有一年，我们有机会去参加金球奖。哦，办公室被提名了。我必须说，首先
of all, Angela, I am so grateful that I got to go to these award show things with you. I know. Well, here's the thing. We didn't go to fancy parties. You guys, we're not fancy people. I'm intimate dinner party person. Well, I like a small group. I think the fanciest parties I'd ever been to were just like one of my friends would have a big wedding. But I am so glad that I got to navigate all that stuff with you because I would normally kind of freeze up at something like that. But I was there with my BFF. We would have a couple glasses of wine. We would sometimes get a little, well, because one thing we should say is we were not allowed to bring a plus one. Well, we were not big time enough. No, I feel like
安吉拉，我太感激能跟你一起去参加这些颁奖典礼了。我知道。不过是这样的。我们没去什么高级派对。伙计们，我们可不是什么上流社会的人。我是那种喜欢举办亲密晚宴派对的人。嗯，我喜欢小团体。我觉得我去过的最最高级的派对，也就是某个朋友举办盛大的婚礼。但我真的很高兴能跟你一起应付所有这些事情，因为遇到这种场合我通常会直接呆住。但我当时和我的最好朋友在一起。我们会喝上几杯酒。我们有时会喝得有点，哦，因为有一件事我们得说，那就是我们不被允许带女伴或男伴。嗯，我们当时还不够大牌。不，我觉得
we were barely invited. Truth be told, even though our show was nominated, it did feel like that. Well, first of all, wait, wait, wait, wait, do you remember where our table was? Very far away from our table was behind a pillar, Jenna. I had to sort of lean all the way like towards Brian's lap to see the stage. Yeah. So the Golden Globes are really cool because they have awards for both movies and television. So there aren't cool movie stars you see. Yeah. As TV people, we were in the room with Angelina Jolie suddenly and Brad Pitt and all those people. We were nowhere near them though. They weren't down at the front and we were in the nosebleeds. But hey, we were in the room. Well, I will say I remember
我们甚至可以说是勉强受邀。说实话，尽管我们的剧被提名了，但感觉确实是这样。嗯，首先，等等，等等，等等，你还记得我们的桌子在哪吗？离得很远，我们的桌子在一根柱子后面，珍娜。我得整个人探出身子，几乎快贴到布莱恩的腿上才能看到舞台。是的。所以金球奖真的很酷，因为他们同时为电影和电视颁奖。所以你能见到很酷的电影明星。对。作为电视圈的人，我们突然和安吉丽娜·朱莉以及布拉德·皮特还有所有那些人在同一个房间里。不过我们离他们十万八千里。他们坐在前排，而我们在山顶观众席。不过嘿，我们在那个房间里。好吧，我得说我记得
going to the bathroom and Angelina Jolie passed by. She took my breath away. I thought, well, now she is from the gods. I get that. I mean, that is a movie star. Well, you turned to me because we were like in line for the bathroom and she just sort of, it's like she glided. It's like she floated past us and you turn to me and you go, now that's a movie star. I did. I saw like an old lady. Now that is a movie star. I was like, I don't disagree, Angelina. So Jen and I are not two people that are invited to a lot of fancy parties. And also if there are going to be two dorks at a party, chances are they're us. Oh yeah. That's just us anywhere. We've done some real dorky things. We are just kind of dorks even
我去洗手间的时候安吉丽娜·朱莉从旁边走过。她让我看得喘不过气来。我想，好吧，她绝对是天神下凡。我懂。我是说，那才是电影明星。嗯，你转向我，因为我们当时在排队上洗手间，她就那样，简直就像是在滑行。她就像是从我们身边飘过去一样，你转向我然后说，那才叫电影明星。我确实这么说了。我看到个老太太。那才叫电影明星。我说，我没有不同意你的看法，安吉丽娜。所以珍娜和我可不是那种会受到邀请去参加很多高级派对的人。而且如果一个派对上有两个书呆子，那十有八九就是我们。哦，是的。在哪儿我们都是这样。我们做过一些真的很书呆子的事。我们就是那种书呆子，哪怕只是在
if it's just like at our neighbor's barbecue. I was glad I got to go to those parties with you because I knew you felt as awkward at them as I did. But you are way braver than I am. That is true. I have a little bit of my mom's voice in my ear and my mom would say, if you are at a fancy party, you need to meet the fancy people. You need to use it as an opportunity. Come on, go say hi to the people you want to say hi to. So I always had that in the back of my head. Like this is my only chance to whatever- Hobnob? Yeah, meet whoever I've always wanted to meet, I guess. But what do you do? How do you get
邻居的烧烤派对上也一样。我很高兴能跟你一起去那些派对，因为我知道你跟我的感觉一样，在那种场合感到很不自在。但你比我勇敢多了。这倒真的。我脑子里一直有个我妈妈的声音在提醒我，我妈妈会说，如果你在一个高级派对上，你需要去认识那些大人物。你需要把这当作一个机会。拜托，去跟你想打招呼的人打个招呼吧。所以我脑子里一直记着这件事。就好像这是我唯一的机会去——高攀？对，去结识我一直想见的人，我猜吧。但你该怎么做？怎么才能
into the conversation is always the mystery. At this Golden Globes- I'm starting to laugh. We had our in. We look across the room and we see Amy Adams talking to Meryl Street. We lean around the pillar. We're sitting behind and we see Amy Adams. You should know at this point, we'd been sitting at our table for quite a while. We hadn't got up and mingled other than we went to the bathroom and saw Angelina Jolie walk by and we didn't say a word. No, I did not speak to her.
加入对话一直是个谜。在这个金球奖上——我开始笑了。我们的机会来了。我们扫视全场，看到艾米·亚当斯正在跟梅丽尔·斯特里普说话。我们从坐着的那根柱子旁探出头去。我们看到了艾米·亚当斯。你们应该知道，那时候我们在桌旁已经坐了挺久了。除了去洗手间看到安吉丽娜·朱莉走过之外，我们没有站起来跟任何人社交，而且我们一句话也没说。不，我没有跟她说话。
We did not speak to her. So Jenna's like, there's Amy Adams. And Angela, she's talking to Meryl Street. We know Amy Adams. Yes. We can go talk to Amy Adams. We know her. She likes us. Yes. And then maybe we'll get to meet some movie stars. Yeah. We'll just basically glom on to Amy Adams was our plan. Yeah. And Jenna was like, come on, Angela, let's go. And I was like, nope, don't want
我们没有跟她说话。所以珍娜就说，看，那是艾米·亚当斯。而且，安吉拉，她在跟梅丽尔·斯特里普说话。我们认识艾米·亚当斯。是的。我们可以去跟艾米·亚当斯说话。我们认识她。她喜欢我们。是的。然后也许我们就能见到一些电影明星了。对。我们的计划基本上就是去死缠烂打艾米·亚当斯。对。然后珍娜就说，走吧，安吉拉，我们去吧。我当时就说，不，不想去。
to go. Not going. Not going. And you really, like, you were like, Angela. I pulled you from the table. I said, we are meeting Meryl Street. We are doing this. This is a story for my mother. Come on. And then she said, and you got to be quick. You have to be quick because what if Amy stops talking to her? Yeah, let's go. And you said, well, what are we going to do? What are we going to say? What are we? How do you walk up to them? What are we going to say? So I was like, here is my plan. We are just going to walk up to them laughing.
不去。不去。而你真的，就像，你对我说，安吉拉。我把你从桌子旁拉起来。我说，我们要去见梅丽尔·斯特里普。我们要这么做。这是个能讲给我妈听的故事。走吧。然后她说，你得快点。你必须快点，万一艾米不跟她聊了呢？对，走吧。然后你说，那我们要怎么办？我们要说什么？我们要怎么走过去？我们要说什么？所以我当时的计划是，我们直接笑着走过去。
What? Just laugh. What? Just. And I said, laugh at what? It doesn't matter. What are we laughing at? I said, it doesn't matter.
什么？直接笑？什么？直接——我说，笑什么？这不重要。我们在笑什么？我说，这不重要。
Jenna, Jenna. Just walk up to them laughing. I think you thought if we just walked up laughing, we would look cool. Like, we're like, I don't know what I thought, Angela. I don't know. I just knew we had to seize the moment. And so we did. Well, I said, I basically was like in shock. I was like, wait, what? And then I looked and Jenna was like four strides away. I committed.
珍娜，珍娜。就笑着走过去。你当时觉得如果我们笑着走过去，就会显得很酷。就像，我不知道我当时是怎么想的，安吉拉。我不知道。我只知道我们必须抓住时机。所以我们真的这么做了。好吧，我当时说，基本上就像是被雷劈了一样处于震惊状态。我说，等等，什么？然后我一看，珍娜已经迈出四步远了。我豁出去了。
You're like, come on. And then I sort of half ass committed behind you. And we did just that. We walked up to Meryl Streep and Amy Adams laughing and right at that moment a house photographer came by and snapped our photo. So we have a photo of us and it looks like we are having a hilarious conversation with Meryl Streep and Amy Adams. Well, actually to clarify, it looks like you and Amy and Meryl Streep are having a great conversation. But because I lagged behind you a little, I was late getting there. And I just look like I'm walking alone laughing. I'm like a good three paces behind you laughing to no one. And you're laughing with Meryl and Amy. But when the lights like flickered
你当时说，走吧。然后我也稀里糊涂地跟在你后面豁出去了。我们真的就这么做了。我们笑着走向梅丽尔·斯特里普和艾米·亚当斯，就在那个瞬间，一个现场摄影师走过来抓拍了我们的照片。所以我们有一张照片，照片里看起来我们正跟梅丽尔·斯特里普和艾米·亚当斯聊得非常开心。好吧，其实澄清一下，看起来是你、艾米和梅丽尔·斯特里普在进行愉快的对话。但因为我落后你一小截，我到的时候比较晚。我看起来就像是一个人走着，在对空气傻笑。我落后你整整三步，对着谁也没笑。而你却在和梅丽尔还有艾米谈笑风生。但当灯光闪烁时
because it was the commercial and we didn't even get to talk to them. I did get to say to Meryl Streep, I did get to say, it's such a pleasure to meet you. I'm a big admirer of your work. And I was, I mean, I just loved her performance in Kramer versus Kramer. I studied a lot of her work. And so as like a theater geek, actor-y person, we've talked a lot about my love of actor prep. That was a big moment for me. Well, I'm glad you had that moment. I did not meet her. Wait, you didn't meet her? No, no, I didn't meet her because they were dimming the lights. And so the like, by the time I got there, I was just like, bye.
因为那是广告时间，我们甚至都没机会跟她们说话。我确实有机会对梅丽尔·斯特里普说，我确实说了，很高兴见到您。我是您作品的超级崇拜者。而且我是说，我太喜欢她在《克莱默夫妇》里的表现了。我研究过她很多作品。所以作为一个戏剧极客、演员型的人，我们聊过很多我对演员案头工作的热爱。那对我来说是个重大的时刻。好吧，我很高兴你有了那一刻。我可没见到她。等等，你没见到她？没有，没有，我没见到她，因为当时灯光正在变暗。所以，等我赶到那儿的时候，我只能说，再见。
Well, she's one of my best friends now. Oh, from that moment. I've never spoken to her again. You've never spoken to her again. My guess is that Meryl Streep doesn't quite remember that moment the way we do. I know. Well, we have a photo of it. We do have a photo. All right, guys, we're going to go to a break. And when we come back, we're going to break down the Hot Girl episode. All right, this episode starts with Michael on a phone call with Jan. She's explaining that they're going to introduce a new incentive program and the top seller in the office is going to get a prize worth $1,000 and that Michael can choose what that prize is. The end.
好吧，她现在是我最好的朋友之一。哦，从那个时刻开始。我再也没跟她说过话。你再也没跟她说过话。我猜梅丽尔·斯特里普对那一刻的记忆可能跟我们不太一样。我知道。不过我们有一张照片。我们确实有一张照片。好吧，伙计们，我们要去休息一下。等我们回来后，我们要剖析“辣妹”这一集。好的，这一集一开始是迈克尔在跟简通电话。她解释说他们要推出一个新的激励计划，办公室里销售额最高的人将获得价值1000美元的奖品，而且迈克尔可以自主选择奖品是什么。结束。
So I love that this episode starts with the line, are you listening to me, Michael? By Jan, because he's just like futzing around with pencils and he has her on speakerphone. But I love that the first scene, you just think he's being an idiot. And then you hear this voice say, are you listening to me, Michael? And I just, I just love it. I love it. The next scene when Dwight is standing over Michael's shoulder in the talking head. It begins as a talking head and then it reveals that Dwight is kind of like hovering. That's the first time we did that. But then we will do that many times in the show. It's one of my favorite things is how Dwight stands over Michael's shoulder. That's also when Pam comes
所以我很喜欢这一集以简的一句“你在听我说话吗，迈克尔？”开场，因为他当时正拿着铅笔瞎忙活，还开了免提。但我喜欢第一个场景，一开始你以为他只是个白痴。然后你听到这个声音说，“你在听我说话吗，迈克尔？”我真的，我太喜欢了。下一个场景，当德怀特站在迈克尔身后的访谈镜头里。它一开始是访谈镜头，然后镜头拉开发现德怀特正像幽灵一样在一旁盘旋。那是我们第一次那样拍。但之后我们在剧中会多次采用这种方式。这是我最喜欢的事情之一，就是德怀特如何站在迈克尔身后。这也是帕姆
into the office to say someone wants to sell handbags and Michael is totally against it, of course, until he sees how attractive the woman is. A lot of people wrote in and wanted to know where did these purses come from that she's selling. So I called Phil Shea. Our prop master. Yes. He told me that he bought them all in downtown LA. Oh, at like the markets downtown? Yes. Oh, the knockoff purse. Yes. Because some of them looked really nice, but also they looked a little like pleather. I don't think anyone kept them. I didn't keep one. Did you? I didn't know we could. I probably would have taken one. It was early on when we weren't brave enough to ask to take things yet. Yeah. No. Later when the show wrapped,
走进办公室说有人想卖手提包的时候，迈克尔当然是坚决反对的，直到他看到这个女人有多迷人。很多人写信来想知道她卖的这些包是从哪来的。所以我打电话给菲尔·谢伊。我们的道具总监。是的。他告诉我这些都是他在洛杉矶市中心买的。哦，是在市中心的集市吗？是的。哦，山寨包。是的。因为有些包看起来真的很不错，但也有些看起来有点像人造革。我觉得没人留着它们。我没留。你留了吗？我当时不知道我们可以留。我大概会拿一个吧。那是早期，我们还不够大胆，不敢要求拿走东西。是的。没有。后来剧集杀青时，
I did take Pam's everyday purse. It's just something that had been sitting. Even if I didn't use it in a scene, it sat on Pam's desk or it was in her drawer. Yeah. So I have that. I have Pam's everyday purse that she had for most of the season. But I didn't keep a fancy purse. There's the scene where Michael has to refer to Katie, the purse girl as Pam 6.0. This was not an improvisation. I have the script. I know. I know. From Hot Girl. I have all the scripts from season one. I saved them speaking of saving things. And I looked it up. She is like the improved version of me. Like she is. Yes, she is. She is not. As your best friend. I am not going to let that slide. She is not. But in this episode,
我拿了帕姆的日常手包。那只是一直放在那儿的东西。即使我没有在某个场景里用过它，它也一直放在帕姆的桌子上或者抽屉里。所以我有那个。我有帕姆在大部分时间里用的日常手包。但我没留什么高级包。有个场景是迈克尔不得不把凯蒂，也就是“包包女孩”称为“帕姆6.0”。这不是即兴发挥。我有剧本。我知道。我知道。来自“辣妹”。我留着第一季所有的剧本。说到保留东西，我都留下了。我查过了。她就像是我的升级版。就像她是。是的，她是的。她才不是。作为你最好的朋友。我绝不会让这种说法过关。她才不是。但在这一集里，
they had really juiced her up. She had a pushup bra on and her hair. It doesn't matter. Even on our plainest day, Amy Adams is Jenna 6.0. She is. No, she's not. It's okay with me. No, I'm not. No. Well, okay. Well, whatever. Shouldn't I have not said that? No, I think you know, I think it's a funny story. But as your best friend, I'm not going to let you say Amy Adams is a better version of you. It's like we look similar, but then her nose is a little dainty here. And her cheeks are a little rosier. And her hair is just a little brighter red. You know what I'm saying? It's just like she just turned it up a couple of notches on the dial and you get Amy Adams. Like if you're creating me, right, you get
他们真的把她好好打扮了一番。她戴着聚拢文胸，还有发型。这都没关系。哪怕在我们最朴素的日子里，艾米·亚当斯也是珍娜6.0。她就是。不，她不是。我倒觉得没关系。不，我不是。好吧，好吧，随便吧。我是不是本来不该说那句话的？不，我觉得你知道，我觉得这是个有趣的故事。但作为你最好的朋友，我可不会让你说艾米·亚当斯是你的升级版。就好像我们长得有点像，但她的鼻子要小巧精致一点。她的双颊更红润一些。她的发色也稍微更鲜亮一点。你知道我在说什么吗？就好像她只是把转盘往上调了几格，就成了艾米·亚当斯。如果按我的底子来塑造，对吧，那就是我。然后如果你把转盘再调高几格，就变成了艾米·亚当斯。她是迪士尼版的你。她确实有点像。她就是我的迪士尼公主版。
to me. And then if you turn the dial couple more notches, it turns into Amy Adams. She's Disney you. She kind of is. She's the Disney princess version of me. Yes. Angela, do you have a note card? Because you're like handling a note card right now. I feel like you want to say a note card. I mean, it's in your hand and then you're touching them. What is it that you want to say? Are you annoyed that I'm touching my note card? No, I'm giving you and I'm giving you a chance to speak. Oh, thank you so much. Oh, so it's British when you were offended. Oh God, no, stop, stop. I was just going to say that Michael Scott has a talking head that I love so much. And these are just one of these talking heads that
是的。安吉拉，你手里有一张索引卡吗？因为你现在正拿着一张索引卡。我觉得你想说索引卡上的内容。我是说，它就在你手里，然后你还在摸它。你到底想说什么？你是不是嫌我摸我的索引卡了？没有，我是在给你机会让你发言。哦，非常感谢。哦，被冒犯的时候就变成英式口音了。噢天哪，不，停下，停下。我只是想说迈克尔·斯科特有一个我非常喜欢的访谈镜头。这些访谈镜头每集都有，每次重新看的时候我都觉得，天哪，太绝了。是关于那个小型商人的吗？还是他读的那些东西？我喜欢他说他最喜欢《美国之路》杂志，也就是机上杂志。然后他说，他们对多丽丝·罗伯茨以及她喜欢在菲尼克斯哪里吃饭做了一篇很棒的专题报道。这真的把我逗得哈哈大笑，因为我也看那些。我想让你们知道，每次我坐飞机时，
they're in every episode and getting to rewatch them. I'm like, Oh my God, that's brilliant. Is it the small businessman? Is it the things that he reads? I love that he said he loves American Way Magazine, the in-flight magazine. And then he goes, they did a great profile on Doris Roberts and where she likes to eat when she's in Phoenix. It just made me laugh so hard because I read those. I just want you to know American Airlines whenever I'm fly with you. I get the American way out and I look to see where people eat. It made me laugh so hard. And then he's like illuminating. I love those magazines too. I read them. I know. And you know, actually one of the coolest things that ever happened to me is that one
只要坐你们公司的航班。我都会拿一本《美国之路》，看看大家都在哪儿吃饭。这真的把我逗得太惨了。然后他还说，很有启发性。我也很喜欢那些杂志。我也看。我知道。而且其实，发生在我身上最酷的事情之一就是，有一次
time I had an article in an in-flight magazine. Yes. Just like the Doris Roberts thing, I got profiled. What? I would be so excited. Why didn't you tell me? That is so cool. No, I told this story about playing poker in Scotland. Oh, wait, wait. I know this is a total tangent. Guys, I'm sorry. I have to take Jenna on a tangent because I love this story. Yeah. Should I tell this story? You have to tell it. Okay. Because first of all, it makes you sound way cooler than you are. No offense. I know. It kind of makes you sound like a rock star. It's my biggest rock star moment of my life. It's 100%. Okay. So I had no, I know you're going to tell that story, but I need to see that in-flight magazine.
我的文章登在了一本机上杂志上。真的。就像多丽丝·罗伯茨那篇报道一样，我被做成了专题人物。什么？我当时会超级兴奋的。你为什么不告诉我？太酷了吧。没有，我讲了这个在苏格兰打扑克的经历。哦，等等，等等。我知道这完全扯远了。伙计们，对不起。我不得不把珍娜带偏，因为我太喜欢这个故事了。是的。我要讲这个故事吗？你必须讲。好的。因为首先，这让你听起来比实际酷多了。无意冒犯。我知道。这听起来有点像摇滚巨星。这是我一生中最高光的摇滚巨星时刻。百分之百是的。好吧。所以我有，我知道你要讲那个故事，但我得看看那本机上杂志。
I'll show it to you. It was for United magazine and they had this story where they wanted people to tell the craziest ways they've ever fought jet lag. Okay. So Lee and I had this little romantic trip that we took to Scotland. This was before we had children. I remember this because you told me you were going and I was like, well, that's not a lot of days. Yeah, we only had five days because we had a one-week hiatus from work. This is what people without children can do. They can just jet off to Scotland for five days. So we were going to spend two days in Edinburgh and then we were going to go into the countryside for the other three days, do a tour of a, you know, like a Scotch factory and everything,
我会给你看的。那是为《联合航空》杂志写的，他们有个故事，想让大家分享他们克服时差的最疯狂方法。好的。所以我和李有一次去苏格兰进行了浪漫的短途旅行。那是我们有孩子之前的事了。我记得这件事，因为你告诉我你要去的时候，我还说，嗯，那也没几天啊。对，我们只有五天时间，因为我们工作上有了一周的假期。这就是没有孩子的才能做的事。他们可以随心所欲地飞去苏格兰待五天。所以我们打算在爱丁堡待两天，然后去乡下待剩下的三天，参观一个，你知道的，苏格兰威士忌酒厂什么的，真的很有趣。所以我们到了那儿，我们想我们可以坐夜航。我们会在飞机上睡觉，然后在中午精神饱满地抵达并开始游览爱丁堡。
really fun. So we get there and we thought we will take an overnight flight. We will sleep on the plane and we will arrive at noon rested and ready to tour Edinburgh. Yeah, right. This did not happen. We did not sleep on the plane and we landed. It was noon and we were thinking how in the world are we going to make it through this whole day. We were exhausted. So tired. We're touring a castle. We're walking along little shops. We bought some hats and a little hat shop. Oh, wait. I know. I know I'm raising my hand because Jenna, you texted me and I remember you saying, we're so tired. We're going to try to power through. We're going to try to power through so we don't fall asleep. Yes. In the middle,
想得美。根本没这回事。我们没在飞机上睡觉，落地时。正值中午，我们心想我们到底要怎么熬过这一整天。我们筋疲力尽。超级累。我们在参观城堡。我们在小商店旁闲逛。我们在一家小帽店里买了几顶帽子。哦，等等。我知道。我知道我举手是因为珍娜，你给我发了短信，我记得你说过，我们太累了。我们要试着硬挺过去。我们要试着硬挺过去，这样就不会睡着了。对。中间，
you can't fall asleep in the middle of the day. Then you're ruined. No. Then the whole five days you're just going to be sleeping during the day and up at night. So it's five o'clock and we are so exhausted. Just so incredibly exhausted. We thought, here's what we're going to do. We're going to go into a little pub. We're going to get a bite to eat. We're going to have a drink. We are going to force ourselves to stay awake until 7pm and then we're going to go back to the hotel and fall asleep. Right. That was your plan. Go to the pub, stay power through and then go to bed. Correct. We get to the pub. We order our drink and we see a sign that says poker tournament starting at 6pm. All right. I have to interject
你可不能在白天睡觉。那你就彻底毁了。没错。那接下来的整整五天你都只能白天睡觉晚上醒着了。所以到了下午五点，我们已经累极了。简直累到不行。我们心想，我们该怎么办。我们要去一家小酒吧。我们要吃点东西。我们要喝一杯。我们要强迫自己坚持到晚上七点，然后回酒店睡觉。没错。这就是你们的计划。去酒吧，硬挺过去然后上床睡觉。完全正确。我们到了酒吧。我们点了一杯饮料，然后看到一个牌子上面写着：下午六点开始扑克锦标赛。好吧。我得插话
here. So my BFF, Jenna Fisher, is a flippin' fantastic poker player. I don't know if I'm fantastic, but I love playing. You are fantastic. Okay. No, you're fantastic. And I once went with her to the Celebrity Poker Showdown story for later, but she's really good at poker. I came in second place. You came in. I mean, that's behind Keegan-Michael Key. He won. That's a big flex because you beat Michael Ian Black who still tells me that you beat him in poker. And I mean, you guys, I also just want to say all of this is before I had children. Yeah. I barely play poker anymore. I can't stay awake for anything. I know, but you are really good. Back in your day, lady. Back in the day. Back in your day before. In my youth.
一下。所以我的好朋友珍娜·菲舍尔，是个超级厉害的扑克高手。我不知道我是不是厉害，但我真的很喜欢玩。你就是厉害。好吧。不，你很厉害。我曾经和她一起去过《名人扑克对决》——以后再讲这个故事，但她真的很擅长扑克。我得了第二名。你得了。我是说，那是在基甘-迈克尔·基之后。他赢了。这真的很牛，因为你赢了迈尔斯·伊恩·布莱克，他到现在还经常跟我说你在扑克牌上赢了他。而且我是说，伙计们，我也想说明所有这些都是在我生孩子之前的事。是的。我现在几乎不玩扑克了。我什么都撑不到那么晚。我知道，但你真的很厉害。当年你也是风光无限啊，女士。当年。在你的全盛时期。在过去。在你的青春岁月。
In your youth. You were quite the poker player. I think I can win poker with like two pairs of threes and I have all the bravado. Two pairs of threes. That would be four of a kind. You can. You can win poker with that, Angela. Okay. So see, this is the problem, but I have no idea what I'm doing. And I think sometimes I mess up a table just because I have such confidence and I have nothing. And then people are like, okay, sometimes that's the best strategy. Okay, go. You're in Scotland. We're in Scotland. You're trying to stay awake. So tired. We sign up for the poker tournament. Lee, my husband, he plays poker as well. We're thinking, here's what we'll do. We'll join the poker tournament at 6pm. We'll be done at 7. This is how we're
在你的青春岁月。你曾经是个相当厉害的扑克玩家。我觉得我可以用两对三赢了扑克，而且我手里全是虚张声势。两对三。那不就是四条吗。你可以的。你完全可以用这个赢扑克，安吉拉。好吧。看，这就是问题所在，但我根本不知道自己在做什么。而且我觉得有时我能把整张桌子的人都搞懵，纯粹是因为我信心十足，但其实我手里什么都没有。然后大家就会想，好吧，有时候这才是最好的策略。好吧，继续。你们在苏格兰。我们在苏格兰。你们在努力保持清醒。超级累。我们报名参加了扑克锦标赛。我的丈夫李，他也玩扑克。我们心想，我们就这么办。我们去参加下午6点的扑克锦标赛。7点就能结束。这就是我们
going to stay awake that extra hour. You're going to play an hour of poker and then you're going to go to bed. Go to bed. We entered the tournament. We start playing. We start winning. You're like the two Americans who came in and now you're kicking butt in this pub in Scotland. So much so that we make it to the final table. What time is this? How long have you been there now? It is now midnight. Oh, Jenna. We are out of our minds. Exhausted. I don't even know what I'm doing. It's probably why I was doing so well because you're so loopy. You're playing the best poker of your life. Lee and I are both at the final table and we keep checking in with each other saying like, should we quit? A couple of times Lee
保持清醒多熬那一小时的方法。你们打算玩一个小时的扑克然后就去睡觉。去睡觉。我们报名了锦标赛。我们开始玩。我们开始赢了。你们就像是两个突然杀进去、现在正在苏格兰的一家酒吧里大杀四方的美国人。甚至于我们闯入了决赛桌。这是几点？你们在那儿待多久了？现在已经是半夜了。噢，珍娜。我们脑子都快转不动了。筋疲力尽。我甚至都不知道自己在干什么。这可能就是我为什么能打得这么好，因为你脑子已经糊涂了。你打出了你一生中最棒的扑克。我和李都进了决赛桌，我们还不断向彼此确认，问我们要不要退赛。好几次李
went all in because he's like, I'm so tired. Just all in and he would win. Finally, I get down to the final two. It's 2am. And it's you and one other person. One local Scottish guy who played every week in the tournament. And here you are. This American tired person on vacation. And I won. You won the whole thing. I won. I won the whole thing. I won 200 pounds. Wow. Amazing. Lee and I couldn't believe it. Everyone in the pub was a little bit like, yay. Yay for her. Did you get your name like up on the wall or something? Yes. I got my name up on the leaderboard and I was supposed to come back for the championship like table that was happening in several months. Of course, we all knew I wasn't going to show
直接全押了，因为他说，我太累了。直接全押，然后他还真赢了。最后，我杀入了最后两人对决。当时是凌晨2点。场上就剩下你和另一个人。一个每周都来参加比赛的当地苏格兰人。而你呢。一个在度假的筋疲力尽的美国人。然后我赢了。你赢了整场比赛。我赢了。我赢了整场比赛。我赢了200英镑。哇。太惊人了。我和李简直不敢相信。酒吧里的每个人都有点像，耶。为她欢呼。你的名字有没有被挂在墙上什么的？有的。我的名字上了排行榜，我本来应该在几个月后回去参加冠军决赛桌的。当然，我们都知道我是不会出现的。所以我想亚军那家伙代替了我的位置。然后我们回了酒店，睡得无比香甜，在那趟旅行的剩余时间里，我一点时差反应都没有。这就是那个故事。这就是发表在《联合航空》杂志上的故事。我为能登上那本杂志感到无比骄傲。我和迈克尔·斯科特同款了。那绝对是一篇非常精彩的读物。我拿到了复印件。我把它寄给了我妈妈。我把它寄给了我的公公婆婆。我家里还有一本。我想让你们知道，当我回到美国本土醒来时。我收到了我位于苏格兰的好朋友发来的短信，上面是她在一家酒吧里的照片。戴着我买的帽子，顺便说一句。戴着你的帽子。我的羊毛帽。而且还在笑，当时我就想，这到底是怎么回事？然后你
up. So I think the runner up guy got to take my place. And then we went back to the hotel and we slept so well and I suffered no jet lag for the rest of that trip. So this was the story. This was the story in the United Magazine. And I was so proud to be in that magazine. I'm with Michael Scott. That would have been a heck of a read. I got copies. I sent them to my mom. I sent them to my in-laws. I have one at home. I want you guys to know I woke up back here in the U.S. of A. And I had a text from my best friend in Scotland and there was a photo of her in a pub. Wearing my hat that I had bought by the way. Wearing your hat. My wool hat. And like smiling and I was like, what is going on? And you were
说，我赢了一场扑克锦标赛。我说，你不是应该在睡觉吗。对。但那是，我是说，那真的可能是我最值得骄傲的时刻之一。是的，那真是个挺摇滚巨星的时刻，女士。谢谢。好吧，我们大概该回到剧集本身了。这是《办公室》迄今为止最让人脚趾抠地的剧集。也不是史上最抠地。我是说，《斯科特的 Tots》才是，但这集确实让人脚趾抠地。“多元文化日”也挺让人脚趾抠地的。不过迈克尔跟凯蒂聊咖啡的整个场景。我当时快笑死了。我快笑死了。当他说，你知道的，我在这里所做的一切只是为了打破壁垒。我只是试着打破壁垒。当时我也觉得超级诡异。我就想，他在胡说八道什么呀？噢天哪。而她
like, I want a poker tournament. I was like, you're supposed to be sleeping. Yeah. But that's, I mean, truly that is like maybe one of my proudest moments. Yeah, that's a pretty rockstar moment, lady. Thank you. Well, we should probably get back to the episode. This is the cringiest episode of the office so far. Not ever. I mean, Scott's tots, but it's cringy. But diversity day is pretty cringy too. But the whole scene where Michael is talking to Katie about coffee. I was dying. I was dying. What I was also got so weirded out when he was like, you know, all I'm trying to do here is just break down walls. I just try to break down walls. I was like, what is he talking about? Oh my goodness. And she
比如，我想办一场扑克锦标赛。我说过，你本该睡觉的。是的。但那，我是说，真的那可能是我的高光时刻之一。是的，那真是个摇滚巨星般的时刻，女士。谢谢。好吧，我们大概该回到正片了。这是《办公室》至今最让人尴尬的一集。也不是有史以来最尴尬的。我是说，斯科特的学员那一集才叫尴尬，但这一集也很尴尬。不过多元化日那一集也挺尴尬的。还有迈克尔和凯蒂谈论咖啡的那整场戏。我简直快笑死了。我简直快笑死了。还有当他说，你知道，我在这里所做的一切只是为了打破隔阂。我只是想打破隔阂。当时我就想，他在胡说些什么啊？哦天哪。而她
plays it so well. Oh my gosh. And then that scene with Brian over my shoulder asking me if I'm jealous. I laughed so hard during that scene. What was difficult was that I was supposed to sit there and be doing my work. And he is hovering over me and then insulting me. And I could not get through it. Every time he would start his sentence, it would make me laugh. That was a scene that I probably laughed the most in when I was shooting this episode. And this leads me into a fan question from Delaney. Did you guys ever get offended by the scripts personally? Like in this episode, how Pam is compared to Katie the whole time? Jenna, did you take that personally? I didn't. Well, I didn't either because I felt like
配合得太好了。天哪。还有布莱恩靠在我肩膀上问我是否吃醋的那场戏。那场戏我笑得太厉害了。困难的是我得坐在那儿假装工作。他一直在旁边徘徊，然后侮辱我。我简直没法演下去。他每说一句话开头，我就会笑场。拍这集时，那大概是我笑得最多的一场戏。这让我想到了德兰妮（Delaney）的一个粉丝提问。你们有没有在私底下被剧本冒犯过？比如在这集里，帕姆一直接着被拿来和凯蒂作比较？珍娜，你介意吗？我没有。嗯，我也没有，因为我觉得
a lot of our comedy was, it was a little bit of a free for all. Like everyone was going to have a moment, you know, where they were sort of the butt of the joke, but it was never malicious. It was just, it served the script. It served the story. I never took offense. Also, I feel like so much of comedy and comedians is self deprecating in nature. And so we're a group of people who are pretty honest with ourselves, don't you think? It wasn't offensive to me. It was also, it was the idea that has happened to all of us where a more attractive person walks in the room and is getting all the attention. And then you feel, you feel jealous, but I enjoyed this episode. I loved playing with all those feelings. I was going
我们的很多喜剧都带有，怎么说，有点百无禁忌的感觉。就像每个人都会有那么一个时刻，你知道的，他们会成为笑柄，但绝不是出于恶意。这只是为了服务剧本。服务剧情。我从来没感到被冒犯。另外，我觉得喜剧和喜剧演员很大程度上带有自嘲的性质。所以我们这群人对自我其实都挺诚实的，你不觉得吗？这对我来说不算冒犯。而且，这也体现了一种我们都经历过的情况——一个更有魅力的人走进房间，吸引了所有人的注意力。然后你会感到，你会觉得嫉妒，但我挺喜欢这集的。我喜欢把玩所有这些情绪。我正要
to say it was a lot of human moments for Pam, just seeing how Jim was affected and how that affected her. And it was fantastic. I thought you did an excellent job. I have on one of my note cards. Where is it Jenna? What does it say? Jenna was brilliant. She was. Thank you, Angela. You were so good. Oh, I don't want to like get us off your, I know you have your list lady, but the moment when she's like, what are you going to do? And he's like, Oh, I think actually I'm going to see Katie. The look on your face as Pam, what you did with your eyes in that moment was so amazing. It was so amazing. You know what I gave myself as a direction in that moment in my head was when he tells you that do not blink your eyes.
说的是，对帕姆来说这有很多走内心的时刻，只是看到吉姆受到的影响以及那对她的影响。这太棒了。我觉得你表现得太出色了。我的卡片上写着一条。珍娜，在哪儿呢？上面写了什么？珍娜太棒了。她确实很棒。谢谢你，安吉拉。你演得太好了。哦，我不想把话题岔开，我知道你带了你的小抄，不过当她说“你打算怎么办？”时，他说：“哦，我想我其实打算去找凯蒂。”你作为帕姆的表情，你当时用的眼神太惊艳了。太惊艳了。你知道我当时在脑海里给自己的导演指令是什么吗？当他对你说那些话时，千万不要眨眼。
Just stare at him. You're not affected by that and smile because that is great new. Oh, that's great. That was her way of trying to not show how she was feeling, but then show it shows everything. Yeah, it showed everything. It was so great. The scene with Katie, Michael and Toby. Oh, brutal. Oh, Jenna, I watched the deleted scenes this time. You did? Yes. So I still haven't gotten a DVD player. How'd you do it? I found him online. Okay. I don't know if it was a legal site that I went to. I went, I clicked on so many things that took me there. So I don't know. I probably have some inappropriate things on my computer now. Oh boy. No, I'm just saying I clicked, I clicked away. But anyway, I watched the deleted scenes
就盯着他看。你没有被那句话影响，而且要笑，因为那是好消息。哦，太棒了。那是她试图掩饰内心情感的方式，但随后却暴露无遗。对，暴露无遗。太棒了。凯蒂、迈克尔和托比的对手戏。哦，太残忍了。哦，珍娜，我这次看了删减片段。你看过？对。所以我还是没买DVD播放器。你是怎么看的？我在网上找到了。好吧。我不知道我点的是不是一个合法的网站。我点了好多链接才找到的。所以我也不知道。我的电脑现在可能存了一些不恰当的东西。哦天哪。不，我是说我点了很多乱七八糟的。不管怎样，我看了删减片段
and there is a longer version of that scene where Steve, I know, is just riffing on that whole idea of sad, sack, Toby. Yeah. And it just, it is so cringy. Oh, I want to go back and watch that. It's really good. So what you see in the episode is just like three seconds of that moment where he's like, Oh yeah, you're divorced, right? Sleeping in your car. I loved the, the you slept one night in your car, right? Yeah. Made me laugh out loud. Yeah. So good for a long time. Yeah. And Paul's reaction is so perfect in the deleted scenes. Michael like goes off on him for like minutes. What's so amazing is that Steve and Paul in real life are both of our kind of very gentle, quiet, kind people on the set. And they have
里面有那场戏的加长版，我知道，史蒂夫就是在即兴发挥关于托比那种可怜虫的整个桥段。对。而且真的让人尴尬癌都犯了。哦，我想回去看看那个。真的很好。所以你在正片里看到的只有那几秒钟的片段，当时他说：“哦，对了，你离婚了对吧？睡在车里。”我特别喜欢那个“你有一天晚上睡在车里，对吧？”“对。”把我逗得哈哈大笑。对。笑好久。对。而且保罗在删减片段里的反应太完美了。迈克尔对他数落了好几分钟。最神奇的是，史蒂夫和保罗在现实生活中都是那种非常温和、安静、善良的人，在片场也是，而他们却
to, well, I guess just Michael has to bully Toby, but Steve and Paul's real life relationship is so opposite that. Yeah. No, but it was, oh, and Katie's like, where am I? Oh, I have some Kinsey tidbits. All right, let's hear them. At eight minutes, 14 seconds, you, Pam, gets up in a huff from Roy and leaves her salad on the table. Yeah. You left your, you didn't pack up your Tupperware or anything and you had a juice box. What are you? I was just been, I had just been insulted. He insulted me. He just, he just said we're dating and I had to say we're not dating. We're engaged. I'm very hurt. And I walk away. What do you want? And here's my salad and my Tupperware. Deal with it. Have you never been at a meal
得，好吧，我猜只有迈克尔必须霸凌托比，但史蒂夫和保罗现实生活中的关系跟那完全相反。对。不，不过，哦，凯蒂说：“我在哪儿？”哦，我有一些金西的八卦小料。好吧，说来听听。在8分14秒时，你，帕姆，气冲冲地从罗伊身边站起来，把沙拉留在了桌上。对。你把你的，你没有收拾你的特百惠（Tupperware）饭盒什么的，你还拿了一个果汁盒。你这是干嘛？我刚刚被羞辱了。他羞辱了我。他刚刚，他刚刚说我们没在约会，而我不得不说我们在约会。我们订婚了。我很受伤。然后我走开了。你想怎样？这是我的沙拉和我的特百惠。看着办吧。你难道从来没有在一顿饭的时候
and been offended and just left your plate? No. So if you're in a fight with someone over dinner, you, you get up with your plate and you go rinse it off and put it in the dishwasher. That's right. I'm going to bust my plate. I'm not going to leave my salad. Well, I would love to see that. Oh, well, I think it would have been so weird if she had taken her food with her. What an odd choice. I thought it was, I think it would be funny if she was mad as hell and had to pack up her salad. I have a thing that I wanted to share about Pam's engagement ring to Roy. The props people, when you have to be married on a show, they'll bring you a whole tray of rings to pick. Yes. You get to pick your engagement ring and your
感到被冒犯然后直接扔下盘子走人的经历吗？没有。所以如果你在吃晚饭时跟人吵架，你，你会端着盘子去把它冲干净然后放进洗碗机吗？没错。我要摔碎我的盘子。我才不会留下我的沙拉。好吧，我很想看看那个。哦，好吧，我觉得如果她把食物一起带走的话会显得好奇怪。多奇怪的选择啊。我觉得，如果她气得要死还得打包沙拉的话，那才叫搞笑呢。我有一件事想分享，关于帕姆和罗伊的订婚戒指。道具组的人，当你在剧中必须订婚时，他们会拿出一整盘戒指让你挑选。对。你可以挑选你的订婚戒指和你的
wedding ring. Now these are based on selections that have been pre-edited by the director and producers, right? So you can't just pick like a honkin ring. Right. It has to match your character's life. Yes. But they give you a variety of things to choose from and you have to try them on different sizes. So when they gave me the tray of rings, I picked a diamond cluster ring as opposed to a diamond solitaire. And I had it in my mind that Pam has always been hurt that Roy didn't get her more of the ring she wanted, which would be more of a diamond solitaire, more of what Jim is going to give her later. Right. But she's a polite person and she thinks this is, it's not right to be offended by the ring
结婚戒指。当然，这些都是基于导演和制片人事先筛选过的选项，对吧？所以你不能随便挑个大钻戒。对。它必须符合你角色的生活。对。但他们会提供各种各样的款式让你选择，你必须试戴不同的尺寸。所以当他们把一盘戒指交给我时，我选了一个钻石群镶戒，而不是单颗钻石戒。我当时心里想的是，帕姆一直对罗伊没有给她买更符合她心意的戒指而感到受伤，她更想要一颗单颗大钻戒，更像吉姆后来送她的那种。对。但她是个礼貌的人，她觉得，因为戒指而感到被冒犯或是不喜欢这个戒指是不对的。
or to not like the ring. So she had to very graciously accept this ring. But I always felt like her opinion of Roy was that he didn't put enough effort into getting to know her or what she would like or he didn't put a lot of effort into the engagement ring or the relationship or the relationship, but that the ring is really a symbol of his lack of effort and his lack of knowing her. And every day when I would look down at that diamond cluster ring, it would just poke at those wounds that she has in her relationship with Roy. And so when he says, boyfriend, that's another way that she's like, that's right. This ring makes me feel like we're not engaged. I've been wearing this diamond cluster ring
所以她不得不非常亲切地接受这枚戒指。但我总觉得她对罗伊的看法是，他没有花足够的精力去了解她，或者了解她喜欢什么，他没有在订婚戒指上或这段感情上花很多心思，或者是说在这段感情上，但戒指确实象征着他缺乏用心，缺乏对她的了解。每天当我低头看着那个钻石群镶戒时，它就会不断刺痛她在与罗伊的感情中所受的伤。所以当他说“女朋友”时，这成了她心想“没错，这枚戒指让我觉得我们根本没订婚”的另一种方式。我已经戴了这枚钻石群镶戒
for three years and it feels like a thing that you give your girlfriend. It doesn't feel like what you give someone when you're proposing, at least for Pam. Does that make sense? It does. And it also just makes me sad. And now I take back my salad, my salad judgment. So you see how hurt she was. You see the history there. She can't clean up a salad in that moment. No. Yeah. No. In that moment, she's like, three years, three years I've sat here and you haven't noticed me. Yes. That's what's raging inside her. And this is probably one of the biggest displays of hurt and anger that Pam has ever had. She doesn't let it out. No. Okay. I take back the salad packing up. Okay. Thank you very
三年了，它感觉就像是你送给女朋友的东西。它不像是求婚时会送的东西，至少对帕姆来说是这样。这说得通吗？说得通。而且这只会让我觉得难过。现在我收回我对沙拉的那个评价。所以你看出她有多受伤了。你看到了其中的历史渊源。她在那种情况下根本没法去收拾沙拉。没法。对。不。在那一刻，她心里想的是：三年了，我在这里坐了三年，而你却没有注意到我。是的。这就是她内心的狂怒。这可能是帕姆有过的最大的一次受伤和愤怒的表现。她平时不发泄出来的。没有。好吧。我收回关于打包沙拉的话。好吧。非常感谢。
much. But do you want to explain to me why at nine minutes, 23 seconds, ET is back on Jim's desk. Wow. Yeah. ET and his blue robe back on Jim's desk. So it was on the desk and then off. Oh, Sam's going to bring up ET. They're looking at, so I make suggestions. Wait for it. Here's the thing. Okay. You just keep talking. See ET? See ET? Where? Where? Oh, yeah. Oh, yes. Yes. I see it. I see it. What is that? I don't know. We need to find out from John. In Phil Shea. We will text John and Phil and get an answer. I have a fan question. Okay. This is from Mary Beth. The scene where Dwight is talking to Katie about buying a purse when Jim and Pam start awkwardly narrating the interaction. Was that
不过你想跟我解释一下，为什么在9分23秒时，E.T.又回到了吉姆的桌上吗？哇。对。E.T.和它的蓝色长袍又回到了吉姆的桌上。所以它一会儿在桌上，一会儿又不在了。哦，萨姆要提起E.T.了。他们在看，所以我来提意见。等着瞧。事情是这样的。好吧。你继续说。看到E.T.了吗？看到E.T.了吗？在哪儿？在哪儿？哦，对。哦，是的。是的。我看到了。我看到了。那是什么？我不知道。我们需要去问问约翰。还有菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）。我们会给约翰和菲尔发信息得到答案。我有一个粉丝提问。好的。这是玛丽·贝思（Mary Beth）提的。
scene scripted or did John and Jenna just play off whatever Rain decided to do? It was improvised. We were on set and we had a little scripted scene and then it was suggested that we narrate what was going on. I think it was John's idea. So Rain knew that we were going to do that. So he started doing all kinds of crazy stuff with the purses, like slamming it on the desk and like trying to put it. Yes, exactly. To give us weird things to say. And I really froze. I am not a great improviser in like comedy improv sketch comedy. I took a couple of those classes and I always really tanked. I froze. I'm very good at improvising in a specific character, but not if the specific character has to be funny and say clever things.
德怀特跟凯蒂谈论买包的那场戏，当时吉姆和帕姆开始尴尬地在一旁旁白解说他们的互动。那场戏是剧本写好的，还是约翰和珍娜根据雷因（Rainn）临时发挥的举动即兴表演的？那是即兴发挥的。我们在片场拍了一场有剧本的戏，然后有人建议我们旁白解说一下当时的情况。我想那是约翰的主意。所以雷因知道我们要这么做。于是他开始对那些包包做各种疯狂的举动，比如把包砸在桌上，还试图把它戴上。是的，没错。给我们制造一些奇怪的台词说。我当时真的呆住了。我可不是个擅长喜剧即兴表演或小品喜剧的人。我上过好几节那样的课，结果总是搞砸。我当时大脑一片空白。我很擅长在扮演特定角色时进行即兴发挥，但如果这个特定角色必须搞笑并说出聪明伶俐的话，那就另当别论了。
It's not my forte. It's okay, lady. You know, you're good at it. You, that was your thing. I love it. I love it. I love it. Just to keep us on plot at this point in the episode, Michael buys a Starbucks coffee machine. A thousand dollars. A thousand dollars. This is going to be the incentive for the salesperson who sells the most, but then he unwraps it and makes Katie the Purse girl a cup of coffee. He's so creepy that he's used this coffee thing to flirt with her. He's so creepy with it. I love his line though, where he says Dunder Mifflin in the 80s before they knew how bad cocaine was. Man, did they move paper. They moved paper. So funny. I love that line. I also remember the scene with Michael and
这不是我的强项。没关系，亲爱的。你知道的，你很擅长。你，那是你的拿手好戏。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。为了让我们回到这集的剧情主线上，迈克尔买了一台星巴克咖啡机。一千美元。一千美元。这将是对卖出最多货的销售员的奖励，但接着他拆开包装，为包包女孩凯蒂倒了一杯咖啡。他太让人毛骨悚然了，竟然用这台咖啡机来调戏她。他在这方面简直油腻得不行。不过我好喜欢他说的这句台词：德温德·米夫林公司在80年代，在他们知道可卡因有多大危害之前。天哪，他们卖的纸可真多。他们卖了好多纸。太搞笑了。我好喜欢那句台词。我还记得迈克尔和
Dwight. Michael tells Dwight that he's going to be giving Katie a ride home and Dwight asking if he loves her. Do you love her? Do you love her? I remember they could not get through that scene. The two of them were cracking each other up. It went on forever. Not only do I love that Dwight is like, do you love her? I love that Michael's like, I don't know. Maybe. I can't say. I can't say. I don't know yet. I don't know. The two of them are ridiculous. And then you have Roy who decides he's going to try to make up with Pam and he decides to start tickling you while you're sitting on Jim's desk. So awkward. Next to Jim. I remember filming that scene. When I watched it, I felt so uncomfortable
德怀特的那场戏。迈克尔告诉德怀特他要送凯蒂回家，德怀特问他是不是爱上了她。你爱她吗？你爱她吗？我记得他们俩那场戏根本拍不下去。他们俩把对方都快笑疯了。拍了老半天。不仅德怀特问“你爱她吗”让我觉得好笑，迈克尔说“我不知道。也许吧。我不能说。我不能说。我还不知道。我不知道”也让我觉得超级搞笑。他们俩简直太荒唐了。然后罗伊决定试着和帕姆重修旧好，他决定开始挠你痒痒，当时你正坐在吉姆的桌子上。尴尬得不行。就在吉姆旁边。我记得拍那场戏的时候。当我看到成片时，我为吉姆感到浑身不自在。我在想，哦天哪，吉姆。然后他站起来走开了。是的。是的。
for Jim. I was like, Oh God, Jim. And then he gets up and he walks away. Yes. Yes. So here's something interesting about that. I, as Jenna, hate being tickled. Yeah, you hate it. I don't like it. It is not. It certainly would not be the way to make up with me. You make you angry. I would be like, no. And I think that when I was filming that, I had to really wrap my head around the fact this is a way that Jenna and Pam are different. Pam is won over by it. Pam is like, Oh, come on. Oh, no. That is how they make up. Yeah. Pam and Roy are friends again, or I guess engaged after that moment. Whatever they are, they're back. Whatever they are, they're back. But for me, as Jenna, I had to really stuff
关于这个有个有趣的事。我，作为珍娜，最讨厌别人挠我痒痒。对，你讨厌。我不喜欢。那绝对不是跟我重修旧好的方式。会让你生气。我会觉得：走开。我想当我拍那场戏时，我必须在脑海里努力消化一个事实：这就是珍娜和帕姆的不同之处。帕姆很吃这一套。帕姆会觉得：哦，得了吧。哦，不。这就是他们言归于好的方式。对。帕姆和罗伊在那之后又成了朋友，或者我猜是订婚了。不管他们是什么状态，他们又和好了。不管他们是什么状态，他们又和好了。但对我来说，作为珍娜，我必须强行压抑我所有的珍娜本能，因为我真的不喜欢被挠痒痒。
all of my Jenna instincts because I do not like tickling. Well, and some people really don't like being tickled. I don't like being scared. Oh, I know. Well, and my husband, like, once a year around Halloween, you don't like being startled or scared. I don't like, I don't like scary movies. You don't respond well. I don't go to scary movies. And my dad was the same way. So you know how they say some people are like, fight or flight? Yeah. I am fight. And, and so Josh, my husband, like around Halloween, him and the kids think it's funny to get like a fake arm or a mask and scare me. And I always say to them, one of you will get whacked. You know that. And I have no, you can flail your arms when people
嗯，有些人确实非常讨厌别人挠痒痒。我不喜欢被吓。哦，我知道。嗯，还有我丈夫，大概每年万圣节前后，你不喜欢被突然吓到或惊吓。我不喜欢，我不喜欢恐怖电影。你对此反应不大好。我不去看恐怖电影。我爸爸也是这样。所以你知道人们常说的“战斗或逃跑”反应吗？对。我是“战斗”。所以乔什，我丈夫，在万圣节前后，他和孩子们觉得拿个假胳膊或面具来吓唬我很有趣。我总是对他们说：你们中总有一天会被揍的。你们知道的。而且我毫无，当别人吓你的时候你就会挥舞胳膊。我见过这种事发生。完全不受控制。就在最近，我丈夫为了万圣节，他们跳出来吓我，戴着这个面具。我尖叫了起来。
scare you. I've seen it happen. No control over it. Just recently, my husband for Halloween, they jumped out to scare me, had this mask on. And I screamed. And then with everything I had, I hooked my phone at him and I hit him with my phone. Clearly, like I didn't mean to. It just is like this weird instinctual thing where I just go, Yeah, you need to hope that you never have to do a scene where someone scares you. It'll be very, because you will. How will you keep your arms from not whacking? I don't know. I don't know. Someone will get hurt. That was the difficulty for me in that scene because tickling me makes me irritated. Want to want to whack someone. Not make me laugh. Well, I thought you did a great job
然后我用尽全身力气，把我的手机朝他扔了过去，用手机砸了他。显然，我不是故意的。这就像是一种奇怪的本能反应，让我直接：对，你得祈祷自己永远不用拍那种别人吓你的戏。那会非常，因为你一定会。你怎么能忍住不挥拳呢？我不知道。我不知道。总会有人受伤的。那才是我在那场戏里的难点，因为挠我痒痒只会让我恼火。让我只想揍人。而不是让我笑出来。嗯，我觉得你演得棒极了。而且尴尬得要命。对，我知道。好吧，我们要进入中场休息了。我们休息一下吧。安吉拉，我想先问你一个问题。好的。你知道德怀特约凯蒂出去的那场戏吗，就在你角色的面前，因为你在看包包？你当时的表情，你在想什么？我甚至都没有抬头。
and it was cringy as heck. Yeah, I know. All right, we're going to go to a break. Let's take a break. Angela, I want to start by asking you a question. Okay. You know the scene where Dwight is asking Katie on the date and it's in front of your character because you're looking at purses? Your face during that moment, what were you thinking? I did not even look up. No, you just kept your eyes down. I kept my eyes down and then I didn't look up until he walked out of the room and you can see when he exits, I kind of look up and look at him leave. You know, in that moment, it was so awkward and uncomfortable. I wasn't given direction to
对，你一直低着头。我一直低着头，直到他走出房间我才抬头，你可以看到他离开时，我稍微抬头看了一眼他离开。你知道，在那个时刻，太尴尬、太难受了。我没有接到导演要我这样做的指令，但我就是觉得太不舒服了。我只能一直看着下面。但“德安吉拉”（D'Wangela）还没正式组CP呢。没有。但把我们后来所知道的你们俩角色的发展，强加到当下的这个时刻是如此轻而易举。不过人们在问，当时你是否知道你们的角色最后会走到一起，但你其实并不知道，对吧？我不知道。我不知道。而且就在那个会议室里，空间并不大。他那样当众向她表白，我作为安吉拉，甚至作为我自己，都觉得太不舒服了，以至于我只想设法不以任何方式参与到那一刻中去。
do that, but I just felt so uncomfortable. I just kept looking down. But D'Wangela is not a thing yet. No. But it is so easy to superimpose what we know is going to happen between your two characters onto this moment. But people were asking if you knew that your characters were going to end up together in that moment yet, but you didn't, right? I didn't know. I didn't know. And just in that conference room, it's not a huge space. And him putting himself out there like that to her, I as Angela and like even as myself felt so uncomfortable that I just was trying somehow not to participate in the moment in any way. Like try to just be invisible. Yeah. I was in my mind, I was like, just be invisible.
就像努力让自己隐形一样。对。我当时心里想的就是：就当自己是隐形人吧。我觉得，你知道的，安吉拉当时并不知道德怀特会成为她的灵魂伴侣，但我觉得她确实把他看作是势均力敌的人，她尊重他的职业道德，可能也尊重他在办公室里的为人，尽管他有时确实惹恼了她，对吧？当然。他们俩之间存在着权力斗争。所以看到他那样向凯蒂放低姿态并受到羞辱，我当时觉得我甚至都不想让他觉得我目睹了这一切。我没看见。这事没发生。没关系。我想这就是她的想法。这就是为什么我没有抬头。我当时真的在努力让自己在那个时刻隐形。嗯，在那之后，你有一句台词，是我最喜欢的你角色的台词之一，你在里面描述了你最喜欢的颜色。这是一个
I think that, you know, Angela didn't know that Dwight was going to be her soulmate, but I think she did see him as an equal and she respected his work ethic and probably respected who he was in the office, even though he annoyed her, right? Sure. There was a power struggle between the two of them. So to see him sort of humble himself like that to Katie and get humiliated, I just felt like I didn't even want him to think that I had witnessed it. I didn't see it. It didn't happen. It's okay. That's I think how what she was thinking. And that's why I didn't look up. I was literally trying to be invisible in the moment. Well, after that, you have a line that is one of my favorite lines of your character where you describe your favorite colors. This is
来自埃米（Emmy）的粉丝提问。安吉拉，你讨论自己喜欢的颜色是不同深浅的灰色的那场戏是即兴发挥的吗？是的，我是。我就知道。是的，我是。在这集里，德怀特正往会议室里看，看着凯蒂和安吉拉在聊天，我们当时没有任何写好的台词。所以他们说：“你们能随便闲聊几句吗？”我当时甚至不知道这会不会被剪进正片里，你知道的？所以那场戏是即兴发挥的。开头是埃米饰演的凯蒂说：“嗯，你似乎喜欢摸东西。”然后我顺着回答：“我倒不是一定喜欢摸东西。我在逛街嘛，你知道的。”我太喜欢那句台词了。接着她说：“嗯，那你喜欢什么颜色？”这些全都是即兴发挥的。我说：“灰色，深灰色，炭灰色。”结果这句台词真的被剪进去了。那可真
a fan question from Emmy. Angela, did you improvise the scene where you discuss your colors being different shades of gray? Yes, I did. I knew it. Yes, I did. In the episode Dwight is looking in at the conference room at Katie and Angela sort of talking, and we didn't have any scripted dialogues. So they said, can you just kind of banter? And I didn't even know if it would make it in, you know? And so that scene was improvised. And it starts off with Amy as Katie saying, well, you seemed to like to touch thing. And then I just responded, I don't like to necessarily touch things. I'm shopping, you know, I loved that line. And then she said, well, what color do you like? And this was all improvised. And I said gray, dark gray charcoal. And it made it in. And that was
是有趣。然后那句台词最后还登上了报纸的一篇文章，文章里在讨论什么台词最能概括这部剧。他们说：“嗯，角色安吉拉的台词‘灰色，深灰色，炭灰色’真的奠定了全剧的基调。”我为此感到无比自豪。那之后，这确实为你的许多戏服提供了参考。你之前一直穿着那种柔和颜色的衣服，但这成了你以后标志性的穿搭。好吧，珍娜，你还有什么？好的，瑞恩和迈克尔清理他车子的那场戏。那可不是即兴发挥的。那是写在剧本里的。很多人问过所有这些：蓝色冲击波（blue blast）、闻起来一样、你到底吃了多少个鱼柳堡？所有这些台词都在剧本里。我查过了，因为我在看的时候，很难相信这不是即兴发挥，于是我特地翻回剧本读了一遍。我觉得这恰恰说明了我们剧的剧本写得有多好。
really fun. And then that line ended up in a article in the newspaper, it was talking about what sums up the show. And they said, well, the character Angela's line gray, dark gray charcoal really sets the tone. And I was so proud of that. It really then informed a lot of your wardrobe after that. You had been kind of wearing these muted colors, but that became your uniform moving forward. Okay, Jenna, what else do you have? All right, the scene where Ryan and Michael are cleaning out his car. That was not improvised. Now that was scripted. A lot of people asked all of it, blue blast, smell alike, how many filet of fish do you eat? All of those lines are in the script. I checked because when I was watching it, it was so hard for me to believe that it was
太棒了。不仅写得好，演员演得也绝了。我是说，BJ和史蒂夫在那场戏里的表现简直绝妙。明迪（Mindy）还告诉我，提到鱼柳堡其实是在向她现实生活中对鱼柳堡那令人发指的热爱致敬。或者只是她对麦当劳的热爱。她超爱麦当劳。但她确实真的很爱鱼柳堡。我也很喜欢那场戏里迈克尔说：“那是一段时间里积攒下来的。好吧。这是一个月里积攒的。”然后临时工瑞恩说：“那也很夸张。”对。那场戏我可以一遍又一遍地看。我觉得太绝了。我觉得如果你还没重温这集，但你在听播客的话，请务必去看一下那场戏。太棒了。好得不得了。蓝色根本不是一种味道。我有一张卡片。读出来吧。好吧。这是一句非常非常棒的德怀特的台词，他说：“施鲁特家族生产非常口渴的婴儿。”
not improvised, that I went back to my script and I read it. And I think that it just points to how good the writing was on our show. Fantastic. Just how good and also how good the actors were. I mean, BJ and Steve in that scene, just absolutely brilliant. Mindy also told me that the reference to the filet of fishes is a nod to her disgusting love of filet of fish in real life. Or just her love for McDonald's. She loves McDonald's. But that she really does love a filet of fish. I loved in the scene too when Michael was like, that was over a period of time. Okay. It was over a month. It was over a month. And Ryan the temp goes, still. Yeah. I could watch that scene over and over again. I think that's a gem. I think if you haven't rewatched this episode, but you're listening
哦，是的。那是句名言。那是句名言。当我怀孕的时候，我是怀着办公室第五季的时候怀孕的，我收到了一件印有“施鲁特家族生产非常口渴的婴儿”的T恤作为礼物。那是一件孕妇装。哦天哪。我挺着个大肚子穿着它到处走，把大家都吓坏了。我到现在还留着它。我到现在还留着它。哦。哦。你有你穿着那件衣服的照片吗？我找找看，如果没有的话，我干脆自己穿上拍张照，然后发到《办公室女士》的播客账号上，因为我还挺喜欢那件衬衫的。
to the podcast, just please go watch that scene. It's so good. It's terrific. Blue is not a flavor. I have a note card. Say it. Okay. This is a great, great Dwight line when he says, Shroots produce very thirsty babies. Oh, yes. That's a famous line. That's a famous line. And when I was pregnant, I was pregnant season five of the office and I got a gift of a t-shirt that said Shroots produce very thirsty babies. And it was a maternity shirt. Oh my God. And I wore that around my big belly and people would freak out. I still have it. I still have it. Oh. Oh. Do you have a picture of yourself in that? I will look, but if I don't, I'll just take a picture of myself in it and I'll have to post that on office ladies pod because I still like that shirt.
你绝对应该发。这里有个大家都在留言讨论的问题。这是我们最受欢迎的问题之一。这集结尾的停车场怎么跟平时不一样？那是因为那是我们搬迁之前的原始片场。前六集，我们都是在卡尔弗城（Culver City）的一栋真正的办公大楼里拍摄的，那个就是那里的停车场。是的。所以当我们在第二季及以后搬迁时，我们有两个摄影棚。一个摄影棚是办公室的复刻版，也就是我们第一年拍摄的那个内部办公室。另一栋楼是编剧们办公的地方。那只是一栋办公大楼，那也是它自带的停车场。是的。那也就是我们拍摄德温德·米夫林停车场的地方。所以这真的很有趣，
You should definitely. Here is something that everybody wrote in about. This was one of our most popular questions. What's up with the wrong parking lot at the end of this episode? That's because this was the original set before we moved. The first six episodes, we all filmed at an actual office building in Culver City and that was the parking lot. Yes. So when we moved in season two and beyond, we had two sound stages. One sound stage was a recreation of the office, that interior office that we shot in the first year. The other building is where the writers worked. And it was just an office building and that was just the parking lot for it. Yes. And that is where we filmed the Dunder Mifflin parking lot. So it was really interesting
因为我们的仓库片场在那边，然后有停车场，还有大厅以及汉克（Hank）坐的电梯。是的。所有这些都在同一栋楼里，但德温德·米夫林的办公大楼又是另一回事。所以如果我们必须拍一场戏，拍到你们看到我们走出来，我们就必须在一栋楼里开始拍摄那场戏，然后把所有的摄像机和我们所有人都搬到另一栋楼去，接着拍摄它的外观镜头。是的。这相当复杂。基本上就是我们在一个摄影棚拍室内戏时，大部分情况下要在另一个摄影棚拍室外戏。但那个停车场并不是你在第二季及以后看到的那个德温德·米夫林的停车场。关于那个停车场，我还有一个故事。你在最后一个镜头里看到，
because we had our warehouse set over there and then we had the parking lot and we had the lobby and the elevator where Hank sat. Yes. All of that was one building, but then the Dunder Mifflin building was something else. So if we had to do a scene where you see us walk out, we would have to start that scene in one building and then move all the cameras and all of us over to the other building and then get the exterior version of it. Yes. It was quite complicated. It was basically when we filmed in one stage indoors, we filmed another stage outdoors for the most part. But that parking lot is not the Dunder Mifflin parking lot that you see from season two and beyond. And I have a story about that parking lot. You see in that final shot, it starts with
一开始是迈克尔、吉姆和凯蒂离开。她拿着个大包。迈克尔意识到吉姆要送她回家，因为他们要去喝一杯。然后镜头切到帕姆和罗伊在罗伊的卡车里倒车，帕姆看到了吉姆和凯蒂。所以大卫和我不得不坐在停车场的那辆卡车里，等了非常长的时间，直到所有人都出来拍完那场戏。我们的卡车里有一个对讲机，他们会说“开始”。然后大卫就会倒车，我们把车开出去，镜头就会拍到我看起来很难过的那个镜头。我们开车离开，然后他们会说“重置”。我们会把卡车开回来，接着我们要等很长时间。到了深夜，他们把我们的车重新停回停车场，我们在那儿坐着，
Michael and Jim and Katie leaving. She's got her big bag. Michael realizes that Jim is going to be giving her ride home because they're going to get drinks. And then it reveals Pam and Roy backing up in Roy's truck and Pam clocks Jim and Katie. So David and I had to sit in that truck in the parking lot and wait a very long time until everyone came out and did that scene. And we had a little walkie-talkie inside the truck and they would say go. And then David would back up and we would pull out and the camera would get that shot of me looking sad. And we would drive off and then they would say reset. And we would bring the truck back and then we would wait a very long time. At the end of the night, they reset us back into the parking lot and we sat there
我们在卡车里坐着。我们在卡车里坐着，然后突然之间，我们看到所有人都开着各自的车离开了。哦，不。他们把我们忘在卡车里了。他们忘了通知我们今天的戏已经拍完了。大家都收工了，准备离开了。你们收工了。你们在换衣服。你们在上车。我们看到导演离开了。我们看到演员们离开了。大卫和我都在想：什么？这到底是怎么回事？所以，事情是这样的。我以前说过这个。大卫·丹曼（David Denman）和我现实生活中是非常好的朋友。我们在聊篮球那集时说过，你和我怎么变成了好朋友，因为我们不得不在那个长椅上坐上好几个小时。这集其实就是我和大卫成为好朋友的契机。嗯，你们有很多
and we sat there in the truck. We sat there in the truck and then all of a sudden we saw everyone driving away in their own cars. Oh no. They left us in the truck. They forgot to tell us that they had wrapped for the day. And we were all done and we were leaving. You were done. You were changing clothes. You were getting in your cars. We saw the director leave. We saw actors. David and I were like, what? What is going on? So and here's the thing. I've talked about this before. David Denman and I were very good friends in real life. We talked about in the basketball episode how you and I became best friends because we had to sit on that bench for hours and hours. This is really the episode where David and I became such good friends. Well, you had a lot of
比如圣路易斯的共同点。我们确实有。我们有共同的朋友。我们还有扑克之交。是的。大卫和我跟我们的剧组工作人员一起打过扑克。我们会组织这些扑克局。雷因也加入其中。克里斯·沃克曼（Chris Workman），我们的摄像师之一，埃德，我们的摄像助理，我们经常聚在一起打扑克。他是其中的一员。所以他也是我的牌友。总之，这集就是我们真正成为朋友的契机，因为我们被忘在了那辆卡车里。你们被困在那辆卡车里了。珍娜，你知道吗？我发现了一个规律，你往往会和那些与你处于狭窄封闭空间里的人成为至交好友。我总是被困住。你被困在长椅上。我会成为安吉拉的至交好友。我被困在卡车里。
like St. Louis connections. We did. We had mutual friends. And we had the poker connection. Yes. David and I played in a poker game together with our crew. We would host these poker games. Rain was in on it. Chris Workman, who was one of our camera operators, Ed, our camera assistant, we would all get together and we would play poker. And he was part of that. So he was one of my poker pals. And anyway, this was the episode where we really became friends because we got left in that truck. You got stuck in that truck. Jenna, do you know what? I'm seeing a theme here that you become really close friends with people that you are in a confined space with. I get stuck with. You're stuck on a bench. I'll be Angela's best friend. I'm stuck in a truck.
大卫，我们来打扑克吧。把我困在电梯里。然后你就会成为至交好友。生死之交。我有了最后一张卡片。准备好了吗？是的。好的。在大约21分25秒时，你会同时看到凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）饰演的梅雷迪思和亨丽埃特（Henriette）饰演的梅雷迪思出现在同一集里。是的，你发现了，安吉拉。是的，我发现了。我差点给你发信息了，背景专家。但我想，不，我要等等看她有没有发现。是的，这是一个巨大的失误。这是一个巨大的失误。所以基本上，当迈克尔在做访谈时，他们想展示办公室里不同女性的各种剪辑片段。他们使用了凯特·弗兰纳里加入之前的试播集的一些素材，那是亨丽埃特饰演的梅雷迪思。
David, let's play poker. Get stuck in an elevator with me. And then you're going to be best friends. Friends for life. I have my final note card. Ready? Yes. All right. At around 21 minutes, 25 seconds, you see both Meredith played by Kate Flannery and Meredith played by Henriette in the same episode. Yes, you saw it, Angela. Yes, I saw it. And I almost texted you, background expert. But I thought, no, I'm going to wait and see if she sees it. Yes, this is a huge mistake. It's a huge mistake. So basically, while Michael has this talking head, they want to show all these clips of different women in the office. And they used like some footage from the pilot before Kate Flannery came on. And it was Henriette as Meredith.
你看到了这个蒙太奇，画面从凯特·弗兰纳里切到亨丽埃特，再切到露安（Luanne），她在附楼演过戏，做过我们很长时间的临时演员。所以这就说得通了。我看到那一幕时，为你感到好兴奋。我太兴奋了，因为你懂得，我知道你一定会注意到的。她知道我把卡片都准备好了。我还有一个最后的小花絮。我有一个，关于费舍尔的小花絮，咖啡机。我们从来不知道是谁赢了那台咖啡机。不，我感觉我特别需要知道。我们从头到尾都不知道是谁赢了，而且我们也再没见过它。所以它没有留在办公室里。我问了菲尔·谢伊，因为有粉丝来信，他们想知道：我们当中有人把它据为己有吗？大家对我们被允许保留和不被允许保留的东西非常感兴趣。我懂的。他说没有。他说那是从星巴克借来的，必须归还。我信。
You have this montage that goes Kate Flannery to Henriette, to Luanne, who played in the Annex, who was one of our extras for a very long time. So that makes sense. I saw that and I got so excited for you. I got so excited because you knew I knew you were going to clock it. She knew I had my note card ready. I have a final little tidbit. I have a, I have a Fisher tidbit, the coffee maker. We never find out who won the coffee maker. No, I'm feeling like I need to know. We never find out who won it and we never see it again. So it doesn't stay in the office. I asked Phil Shea, because a fan wrote in, they wanted to know, did any of us get to keep it? People are very interested in the things we're allowed to keep and not keep. I get it. He said no. He said it was borrowed
那台机器现在在哪儿？我其实挺相信的，我敢打赌那些包包也都退回去了，因为我们当时预算紧张，而且我们以为节目要被砍了，我们不想给NBC任何借口觉得我们在惹麻烦。没错。所以我相信所有这些东西都退回去了，我们还得把那笔钱拿去冲抵。肯定的。好吧，珍娜，我觉得这些是一些非常有趣且节奏明快的冷知识。你做得太棒了。哇。谢谢你。不客气。我真的很感激，安吉拉。我觉得我现在需要听你唱首歌，如果这就是你的歌喉的话，我刚刚意识到我们从来没有一起去唱过卡拉OK什么的。在爱的翅膀上，只有我们俩一起飞翔和躲藏。好了。别唱了。
from Starbucks and had to be returned. I believe that. Where is that machine now? I actually believe that and I bet the purses were returned because we were on a tight budget and we thought we were getting canceled and we didn't want to give NBC any reason to think we were trouble. That's right. So I think I believe that all of that was returned and we got to recoup that money. For sure. Well, Jenna, I think that was some really fun fast facts. You did a great job. Wow. Thank you. You're welcome. I really appreciate it, Angela. I think now I need to hear you sing, because if that's what you sound like, I just realized we've never like done karaoke or anything together. On the wings of love, only the two of us together fly and hide. Okay. Don't sing anymore.
我们可付不起版权费。不过现在我知道了，现在我听过你的卡拉OK歌喉了，而且是气音版的。是耳语般的。它是在试图掩盖我的缺点。而且如果你真的不会唱歌，你就会用气音唱。那是《辣妹》（Hot Girl）。第一季到这里就全部结束了。第一季里，你和我成为了至交好友，因为你当时被困在长椅上跟我在一起。对。而且在那里你还和某人成为了朋友，因为你被困在一辆车里。对。看到了吧，规律这不就来了。第二季会发生什么呢？在第二季里我会和谁被困在一起呢？咚，咚，咚。说到第二季，我们将从“丹迪奖”（The Dundies）开始。哦，我等不及了。那可是一集大制作。非常非常重磅的一集。好吧。我们下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
We have to pay for it. But now I know you're, now I have got your karaoke voice and it's whispery. It's whispering. It's trying to cover up my flaws. And if you can't really sing, you whisper sing. And that was hot girl. And that wraps up season one. Season one where you and I become best friends because you were stuck on a bench with me. Yeah. And where you also became friends with someone because you were stuck in a car with them. Yeah. See a pattern here. What's going to happen season two? Who do I get stuck with in season two? Dun, dun, dun. Speaking of season two, we are going to start with the Dundee. Oh, I can't wait. That's a big episode. A very, very big episode. All right. We'll see you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office
《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀（Sam Keeper）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。请记住，你可以在Stitcher Premium上收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本。想要免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：office。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Keeper. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Remember you can listen to ad-free versions of Office Ladies on Stitcher Premium. For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
女士们。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。请记住，您可以在 Stitcher Premium 上收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本。要免费获得一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 office。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。